austin texas is where emily joins us
emily how can we help
hey so i kind of have a financial slash
dating question um my question is how to
identify financial red flags when dating
someone
especially early on i you know hindsight
of course is 20 20
and i recently you know found myself
dating someone
who had their car declined a couple
times on you know really small brunches
and was pulling out a lot of money from
his 401k
to buy a house that was going to have an
unreasonable mortgage
and things like that and i kind of you
know
glazed over it and kind of like he'll
figure it out or whatever but in
my head i knew there were poor decisions
and something not lining up right
so i feel like i kind of spend a lot
more time
dating someone than i should
when i when i am told these things and
find out this information i
should kind of be like okay you know
this isn't for me because this is
actively happening and you think it's a
good idea
and i don't you know and these are
really big decisions being made
so how do i identify and acknowledge
financial red flags
anthony are looking at each other going
who's going to go first on this um
well uh i think you've identified those
red flags don't you
i mean they're just the ones you gave us
uh are you saying that you didn't
identify them initially and now you're
aware of them is that what you're saying
yeah so in the moment i'm like i think i
kind of glaze over them
or maybe um like lesson watered them
down in my head just because i'm
personally you know on a
debt payoff journey no no no no
no no no let me tell you what's going on
so that's what i thought so you knew
those were red flags then
and you chose not to do anything about
them and that's a that's a relationship
thing that's a thing inside of you
that's an emotional thing inside of you
i'm not ready to tell you what that is
but i think that you could probably tell
us
if you're honest with yourself there's
something emotionally happening to you
when you see this and you go this is not
good this is completely opposite of what
i think about money
and i'm not going to say anything about
it just because i don't want to be
lonely or i don't want to be rejected i
don't know what is it
that's what i want to know what do you
think it is
um you know i think i kind of am
an over giver and i easily
feel bad for people so i'm kind of like
oh you know maybe i can just
help guide the way or you know give
advice along the way
like i don't know i i start to think of
how
i can maybe overcompensate did you do
that
in that past relationship i'm guessing
this is in the past correct
oh yes did you give it did you did you
teach did you give advice and then how
did he react
um yeah and i actually would bring up
like dave ramsey
and you know those steps and things and
how i'm selling them
and i kind of got the shrug of the
shoulders and the kind of like ah
maybe i don't know about that and i even
got maybe one time i don't think you
should listen to that guy um
so there's your sign
yeah and yeah so it's definitely in the
moment thing i don't know i'm
too nice yeah there is something it
could be a lonely
factor that you're talking about there
but i'm gonna i'm gonna let i want i
want ao to jump in because
he's single and this is a guy who's very
public about his financial stances and
so
he runs into this way more i've been
married almost 23 years so
i i you know look i'm gonna speak to you
almost like
maybe the uncle for a moment um i think
you're really clear on what the red
flags are and you identified them
and i actually don't mind you you know
you're dating a young man and
and uh he's doing things like that you
go that's kind of not what i believe at
all that
and been you going hey listen i noticed
this this and this
don't embarrass you this is what i
believe about money what are your
thoughts on money
i mean i think it's just as much of a
relevant topic is what do you think
about kids and what do you think about
uh religion and faith these are all
things that eventually you got to talk
about anyway
so i don't think you harp on it but i
think if you give
your opinion on it say hey i can help
you with this i can teach you how to
budget we can go to this class together
and if a dude's really invested in you
number one and number two healthy enough
to go
yeah i can acknowledge i don't know
anything about money and i'm just kind
of doing what i thought
then i'm fine with those red flags
because all of a sudden those become
caution flags yellow
and then we could turn those into green
flags that'd be my take ao
but if if they're making fun of you and
going you don't need to listen to that
guy
then we have a clear separation on
values and that money problem
will never go away even if you get
married yeah yeah no
and i'm so glad that you said that uh
ken uh emily uh kim was going right
where
i was going i wrote down two things
number one you need to identify
what are your financial values uh that
you stand
true to and then while you're dating
someone and as you're getting to know
someone
you need to see if you're equally yoked
in those areas all right
because here's the truth um our ramsey
tribe our ramsey way is different from
what culture is saying
so you got to identify is this a red
flag or is it a yellow flag
there's a difference between someone who
is uneducated who needs
education like what kim was hinting to
uh then someone who just says you know i
have the education
and i don't care this is what i want to
do i want i want to rack up debt i want
to do this i want to do that
that is something that you know if you
don't line up with those values you need
to separate yourself from
doesn't make them a bad person it just
makes them hey we're not equally yo
we're not going down the same direction
cool beans great but there are a lot of
people out there who are just
financially illiterate you know like you
said uh taking out the 401k
and they go um do a home yeah that just
means he needs education on why that's
not
acceptable you know swiping a credit
card to um
pay for dinner that that's just
unacceptable and so
you know i think when we are dating
number one we have to identify
our financial values the number two is
let's not
hold someone accountable and
automatically say these are huge red
flags and they're a horrible person
uh because they're just not as educated
just try exposing him to
your way of thinking in your way of
processing finances
and then if and over time if you see he
or she america whoever you're dating
do not line up with what you believe in
then you got to separate yourself you
know um
ken i'm single and i'm not do this
absolutely
i've seen ao folks like being in serious
relationships and then something that is
a big value issue how much time do you
give it
i mean i i give it a little bit of time
and what is involved in that time
within the first 90 days i identify okay
hey listen do we have the same
values financially now again i'm 36 i'm
turning 37 i desire marriage
you know uh sooner than later i'm about
to turn 40. so my my value is a little
bit different but for me
my main thing is do we do we both agree
on avoiding debt
that's number one number two when do we
both agree on building wealth and and
leaving a legacy
uh those that's number two the number
three is do we really which
should be number one do we believe in
being a good steward and giving a ten
percent
if we don't if we don't agree on those
three things i cannot be with her
she's a great individual but she's just
not my great individual to be my wife
yeah bottom line yeah and we don't have
time to discuss is going to break but
i'm guessing you do that in other areas
of your life as well not just the
finances yeah
absolutely here are the key values yes
and look it stinks
yes if you've got a great relationship
but but you just go hey this is not
going to have a long-term potential so
you're out
right yeah i believe the word that he
uses he bounces
i like that that's uh that's positive
that's not a breakup
i'm bouncing i'm bouncing to the next i
love that well i'll kick rocks